[Música]
ah
todos hemos soñado alguna vez con tener
una casa sea bien cuando éramos niños
pequeños
estábamos en kínder dibujamos esos
retazos rectangulares con dos ventanas
cuadradas un techo triangular una
pequeña chimenea o sea bien un poco más
adelante en la vida cuando ya teníamos
cierta expectativa respecto a comprarnos
el departamento espero sea bien un
escenario o sea el otro al haber soñado
con esta casa surge cierta incógnita y
es que hasta cuándo vamos a vivir en
casa de nuestros padres
bueno puede ser un tío pueden ser
nuestros abuelos o algún familiar
planteando la pregunta de otra manera
podríamos tal vez preguntarnos
porque la mayoría de los jóvenes en
américa latina vive con sus padres hasta
los 30 años que si vemos a nuestro
alrededor es algo que de hecho es
bastante común
podríamos tal vez abordar a esa pregunta
desde una perspectiva social
tal vez se trata de quiénes somos
nuestra identidad tal vez es cultural
tal vez es algo intrínseco de nuestro
ser latino
bueno si ese fuera el caso tendría que
haber evidencia alrededor y que de hecho
si vemos en la ciudad la hay vemos que
las casas se apilan unas encima de otras
y es bastante común que se construye una
casa en la cual el primer piso es para
los abuelos en el segundo piso viven
nuestros tíos en un tercer piso estamos
nosotros con nuestros padres y los
derechos de hecho son de calamina para
que sea fácil retirar los y podamos
construir un quinto o sexto piso cuando
llegue el momento
nos agrupamos como las aves sin dejar el
nido
sin embargo si vemos en nuestro entorno
especialmente en las redes sociales e
internet vemos que se habla mucho de las
nuevas generaciones
los llamados millennials los zetas
grupos a los cuales de alguna forma
también corresponde características de
estos grupos son el creer viajar salir
al mundo explorar ir más allá
y bueno si fuera el caso entonces que
nosotros generacionalmente deseamos
abandonar el nido por un tema coyuntural
respecto a quienes somos como grupo
milenia los zetas
debería haber también evidencia de ello
en el mercado inmobiliario
si hacemos cierto análisis vemos que
anteriormente existía ya un paradigma
respecto a cómo es que íbamos a adquirir
nuestro hogar y durante mucho tiempo se
vivió bajo el modelo industrial donde la
gente en primer lugar hacía carrera en
una universidad estudiada conseguían
trabajo y van ascendiendo conseguían de
realmente una hipoteca se casaban tenían
hijos pero si vemos la realidad actual
este paradigma pareciese haber cambiado
siendo la hipoteca tal vez la última
cosa en nuestra lista de actividades
porque es esto
yendo hacia el paradigma que habíamos
mencionado
vemos en internet que se busca tres
veces más casas en venta de lo que se
buscan casas en alquiler entonces no hay
tal cosa como que los jóvenes desean
viajar por el mundo constantemente sin
aterrizar en un lugar de manera
permanente y que por ello pues viven
alquilando porque no está entre sus
intereses el comprar la gente busca
casas en compra tres veces más de lo que
se busca en casas en alquiler y no
solamente ello sino que es una tendencia
a nivel global a nivel mundial la gente
busca casas en venta en más de lo que
busca casas en alquiler y no es en
particular que busquen en cualquier
lugar para vivir sino que se buscan
casas y no así departamentos
esto evidentemente tendría que también
reflejarse no solo en el mercado
inmobiliario sino también en los medios
en las noticias y de hecho es el caso si
vemos principales titulares de distintos
medios podremos encontrar que existe un
cambio en el mercado inmobiliario a raíz
de cómo viven estas nuevas generaciones
los millennials quienes de hecho son
sólo el 15% de los compradores de casas
la mayoría de ellos optan por un
alquiler no porque les guste sino porque
simplemente no pueden acceder a comprar
una casa
y de hecho los alquileres son bastante
fuertes ahogando el estilo de vida que
tienen muchos jóvenes ya que el 65% de
nuestro salario se va a pagar la renta
regresemos hacia el modelo tradicional
que habíamos visto el hacer carrera si
partimos desde este punto podríamos tal
vez encontrar el por qué no estamos
adquiriendo este hogar soñar
desde esa perspectiva podríamos
mencionar que tal vez no solamente es
cultural ya que vemos que la gente
efectivamente quiere emigrar quiere
dejar su hogar quiere adquirir una casa
propia sino que además de este factor
cultural hay de por medio un detalle
económico
de forma rápida les comento que lo que
hice fue lo siguiente
calculé y también obtuve la información
respecto a el costo promedio de
distintas casas en américa latina y lo
contraste versus el sueldo promedio que
se ganaba en los distintos países que
considere en una muestra
toda esa información tenía que
naturalmente desembocar se en un excel
una tabla enorme donde considere las 19
ciudades más pobladas considerando tres
casas y tres departamentos para cada uno
de estos en sus principales barrios
módicos cruzando esta información si
sabemos cuánto gana la gente y sabemos
cuánto cuestan las casas
podríamos simplemente hacer un pequeño
cruce y pues determinar en cuánto tiempo
se llegaría a comprar uno esta casa y
efectivamente ese sería el siguiente
paso de nuestro análisis
hasta aquí con la información encontrada
llegué a darme cuenta de que la caja
promedio en américa latina' cuesta 121
mil dólares teniendo 130 metros
cuadrados aproximadamente un
departamento no dista demasiado de este
precio cotizándose en 110 mil dólares y
teniendo 83 metros cuadrados y solo como
un dato adicional valga mencionar que el
latino promedio ahorra aproximadamente
30 dólares al mes
con esta información generemos tres
escenarios supongamos que hay un joven
quien vive con sus padres no gasta un
solo centavo y ahorra el 100% de su
sueldo cuánto tiempo le tomaría a esa
persona comprar esta casa en un segundo
escenario podríamos ver a alguien que
bueno si cubre sus gastos pero como vive
con su familia no paga alquiler y este
monto además del ahorro tradicional si
puede efectivamente guardarlo para esa
casa futura y veamos un tercer escenario
también de alguien quien tiene que pagar
alquiler tiene que cubrir sus gastos
por ende solamente le queda un pequeño
margen de ahorro para esa casa soñada
considerando estos tres escenarios y
considerando toda la información
anterior estos son los tiempos que toma
comprar una casa en américa latina'
bajo estos escenarios vemos que a la
primera persona le tomaría veinte años y
tres meses comprar una casa promedio en
la región vemos que en un segundo
escenario el tiempo sube a 30 años y que
para aquel quien tiene que cubrir todos
sus gastos y no cuenta con algún tipo de
ayuda familiar el tiempo es muy extenso
pero en un momento cualquiera podría
decir que tengo un primo que bueno pues
a los 30 salió de su casa y como me
dices que a los jugadores a los 20 años
esto no terminaría comprando este hogar
si hacen el cálculo desde uno termina la
carrera hasta que ahorra y demás
estaríamos hablando de independizarnos
en nuestros 40 tal vez 50
momentito
hay dos factores adicionales a
considerar en este modelo tradicional la
mayoría de los latinos como latinos que
somos nos ayudamos nos ayudamos entre
familia nos ayudamos entre amigos y es
por ello que la mayoría de nosotros de
alguna forma accede a cierto tipo de
ayuda económica familiar esto disminuye
el tiempo necesario para poder comprar
esta casa bien sea que nos den un pie de
capital para un anticrético sean veinte
mil dólares para poder empezar en este
camino hacia la independencia o bien sea
por la otra alternativa un préstamo
bancario un mix de las dos
estos factores hacen que los tiempos
efectivamente bajen disminuyan
además claro no pueden cambiar sus
expectativas no apuntar a un
departamento con estos costos sino tal
vez ir a algo más barato
pero desafortunadamente el acceder a
estas dos opciones no es una realidad
para muchas personas millones de jóvenes
en toda la región
podríamos decir entonces que tiene que
haber un cambio en el paradigma no
solamente en el sentido de que la
fórmula tradicional es la receta para
comprar nuestro hogar ya no funciona del
todo sino que existe también la
necesidad de cambiar nuestra mentalidad
respecto a cómo deberíamos conseguir
esas casas de los sueños y qué
características debería tener la misma
por la coyuntura sociocultural y
económica en la cual vivimos
solamente el año pasado en eeuu 79
millones de personas tuvieron room it's
valga decir que vivieron con alguien que
no era exactamente su familia bien puede
ser un extraño bien puede ser un amigo
pero compartieron pisos esta es una de
muchas alternativas que existen dentro
del universo de economía colaborativa
donde vemos que hay otras alternativas
otras soluciones porque si nos quedamos
con ese modelo tradicional nos
estaríamos quedando en las nubes soñando
en algo que ya no es realista ya no es
tan fácil acceder al logro de esta meta
como hace un tiempo sí lo era
por tanto debemos abrir nuestra mente
considerar que estamos aquí de paso solo
una vez y si solamente tenemos esta vida
porque no aprovecharla porque no cambiar
nuestra mentalidad porque no buscar
otras opciones otras alternativas porque
no ayudar también a otras personas a
quienes no pueden acceder a alternativas
tradicionales porque no colaborar con
otros jóvenes
ya que solamente estamos aquí una vez yo
les sugiero y les invitó a que
aprovechemos la oportunidad